hello welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sockin today we're sitting down
with Joshua Kaufman now I'm really good
to see you Oh handshake let's get to see
you man give me a hug yes how we usually
do it it's we talk all the time at the
theme and we talk all the time but this
is a special occasion where we get to do
it in the context of the simulation with
all the robotic cameras that you have
and in this brand-new studio that you
have - I'm really excited to talk with
you until we arrive and to learn what's
happening with the simulation and how I
can be helpful to it thank you
and I've Joshua really fascinated me
from the first time that we talked I
just I really felt a deep emotional
connection for you to what you're
building into the world most people
don't have that self actualization but
even furthermore your emotional
connection isn't just - you know
building something that it provides
value but it's also geared towards
something that is extremely important
for things like planetary health and a
lot of people don't think about that and
so when we were talking about it you
were very interdisciplinary you were
very you were very concerned with how
you allocated your time and I thought
that those things were things that I
also am striving to get better at so I
really resonated with you a lot from
when we first met so this is gonna be
great thanks man mutual admiration
you've been really nice being it it's
been really nice being in the audience
as you've interviewed people who are
intellectual heroes of mine and - so
forthcoming about your own personal
growth and to see you grow as an
interviewer and interlocutor in public
is really cool - thank you I think that
one of the principal challenges with
thought leadership is that people feel
like they need to have a fully form
thought then they need to come into the
world with a fully form of thought
that's impervious to criticism that is
defensible in an Oxford style debate
against the smartest people in the world
and what we end up having is a bunch of
individuals sitting on stages with
calcified opinions that end up
territorial izing it against insurgents
against young people against people who
may be working a nine-to-five job and
don't have the time
read the books in order to fortify their
opinions and and what I love about what
you've done so far with the simulation
is you're not afraid to be onstage and
to say I don't know and you provide an
environment with the people that you're
interviewing where it's comfortable and
appropriate for them to say I don't know
and where it's comfortable to be in the
process of developing an opinion rather
than having a fully-formed opinion as if
the only valid thought is one that can
be put onto a TED stage and suffer or
benefit from instant adoration non-stop
applause and millions of views to
solidify the you know reality of you as
being a valid thinker in the world so
thank you so that's a toast to I think
you providing an environment in which
people can form their thoughts in a safe
manner and take external criticism as
something that can add to the way that a
thought gets put together rather than
hunkering down and being overly
defensive about it
no no kinder words have been spoken yet
on the show it's also a wish for you to
I mean it's a I mean as your friend
thank you I want that to exist in the
world yeah we talked about that in great
depth like on one of our first couple
hangouts and that also really resonated
with me and so this idea of what you
bring up about being okay with not
knowing and being vulnerable about not
knowing I really love that so much and I
think it's crucial in not only
conversation but also in sharing and
disseminating ideas and that's right the
way that we should potentially build the
future to say that you know I don't know
but it seems like clean meat is a really
good idea you know things like that you
know I think that people will resonate
with that well and then there's always
gonna be that person that might say that
no you know I really like to consume
animals for these reasons and then you
might say you know why tell me about
your journey what led you to that point
or especially in the political sphere
right that was this very scientific
point but it's even more polarizing in
the
political sphere having good
conversations and knowing how to have
outstanding conversations is an art that
has fallen into a into kind of a hole
that we're digging it out of and a part
of the hole is social media echo
chambers and we talked about you know
time will spent and and these movements
that are really trying to diagnose it
for us I mean you're you're in the
business literally in the business of
elevating voices so you see people as
they appear in the world and they come
into this amazing studio and then you
see them sit down beside you or sit down
in a stage in another sort of
environment and then you see the public
persona turn-on and then you see them
say the things that the audiences want
to hear that's crazy act one thing I
definitely want to talk with you about
but I'm terribly ill informed about is
this this person Jordan Peterson this
lightning rod who you chose to bring
into your house I didn't see that the
session that you did unfortunately I was
out of town at the time but what I
really wanted you there but what I
really wanted to be there what a
flashpoint and it's hard not to think
cynically that a reason why an
impresario like yourself who's
interested in the dissemination of ideas
and possibly in the future the
dissemination of questions which is
probably a more yeah important and
defiantly cool way did that way to do it
it's hard not to see it cynically that
you're gonna you're gonna cultivate your
own centrality by parasitically
attaching yourself to the individuals
who themselves have growing audiences in
the same way that they do to you and
it's a it's a reciprocity that we
understand happens in the world you have
the dissemination of ideas but a person
who is so connect rhyming about that
before we have any time though this is
your show [ __ ] check check out what
within what you just said I'll give a
story before we get there that I think
you'll find very interesting
Justin musk and I have been talking a
lot about this and other people and I
have been talking a lot about this I
really respect her a lot and we're gonna
be hosting her at a
event on the 20th of May yeah in about
like the 300-seat theater in San
Francisco be nice they'll be nice little
mini simulation event there's a strange
there are strange fortresses and walls
and moats
and all these things that are placed
around people medieval metaphors placed
around people
medieval metal go ahead and bring them
all out they they they have you know
archer towers and catapults in the back
and they have all this stuff that is
protecting them from others and the
essence of why they have that is to
prevent snakes from getting in but also
what that does is it prevents young
ambitious intelligent people from
helping them and like you described that
symbiotic attachment that occurs or they
both feed off one another and play and
advance both ideas it doesn't happen as
often because of these massive freakin
moats and fortresses and archer towers
and stuff like yeah I mean I love the
metaphors that you're using I think that
we should also call up these people for
what they are I mean they have for
whatever reason consciously or
subconsciously figured out that the cult
of personality is the ultimate form of
self territorial power and all the
dynamics are at played to elevate these
individuals because this is how the
Pareto principle dynamics of social
media work but beyond that this is also
the way that these individuals have
determined to maximally stimulate the
minds of people longing for meaning
those who are lost those who are
unresolved yeah and specifically the
most susceptible and the most
impressionable those who don't
necessarily have the capacity to be
contemplative and reflective and
genuinely curious but who react to the
strong man and react to the ideological
authoritarian or the political
authoritarian because they seem to have
all the answers and let's just say that
you're a person who assumes that the
person who says that they have all the
answers does have all the answers well
that's quite a community position to put
yourself in because it relieves you of
the COG
of burden of the actual hard work of
looking at the totality of all the
possible thoughts yeah and the totality
of all the possible counter thoughts and
the and the actual difficulty of making
up your own mind it's very very hard to
do and a neil degrasse tyson wrote about
it at the end of his book asked physics
for people in a hurry he spoke about how
how grateful we must be in order to have
enough time to contemplate the cosmos
because so many people don't in the
sense of living in massive metropolitan
areas that have tons of light pollution
and where they're just paying for their
rent and their food and their insurance
and then at the end of their check cycle
that down almost zero and there is no
ability for them to do so so I like the
light pollution reference in there to in
the sense that it makes it hard to look
up I mean the cosmos is everywhere it's
not just up in the sky yeah but most
definitely it's the poetic direction we
should look if we're gonna think about
the cosmos and even the pole political
sphere it's easier to latch on to
somebody that is in the media spotlight
with the Pareto principle fault their
distribution of content is just vastly
more people talking about Trump and
Peterson people like that then there are
talking about Coffman then there are
talking about a simulation no God forbid
I mean that's but that's the irony is
that in every instance in which a person
like myself or yourself is wondering
well how can I have more positive
influence in the world the way that that
person is consulted using just
commonsensical status quo thinking as
well you need to elevate your role in
the world more people need to know about
Alan and more people need to know about
Joshua even if what you're representing
is a demotion of the cult of personality
you then end up becoming this ironic or
hypocritical figure who had who suffers
from the cult of personality but it was
actually trying to rail against it the
the irony that's inside of that I mean
that's that's the the greatest
compassion that I have
what I think you're going to try to
achieve is that you're gonna try to
elevate your own status in the world
wall at the same time demoting your own
status and elevating the status of the
question whatever that hard question
right now it's the question that's
imprinted on that mug over there do you
believe we are in a computer simulation
it's very subliminal I'm glad you caught
it Zoltan yesterday right over my
shoulder there
because I know you're gonna ask me that
question you're you're so interestingly
on point about the elevating the
question and the importance of that just
yesterday with with Andre kun over the
CEO and founder of Silicon Valley
Innovation Center and with so many other
people that have come into this room
I've made it crystal clear that the
money is not important the impact is
important the impact is most important
the elevating the question is most
important this flesh vehicle this meat
puppet is going to live and die but if
we can disseminate these
thought-provoking questions to more
people across the world and then pass it
down that's what will actually build the
future of the world I haven't heard
people going around saying hey did you
see the question that was asked I think
that's the crux of it if you can get to
the bottom of that dynamic yeah it's
very hard to describe a question yeah
very hard to describe why a question is
a compelling question unless you have
the tools or the wherewithal to begin
even answering that question which is
why we're not transmitting virally
questions to each other we're
transmitting answers for the most part
yeah and again it's the cognitive ease
because the question all makes me do
effort it gives me I have to do things
yes it's a question it else implies that
nobody knows and if nobody knows yeah
and presumably then there's no power
yeah so where's the power in staying in
that space where you're answering the
question without necessarily having an
answer per se or where you can issue our
best guess at the moment like the cosmos
psychism is like the best guess for the
way that consciousness is infused in the
universe or pants IKOS ism is another
way of saying there's a few other ways
of do we really know now we don't know
but we think that this is a theory worth
exploring and we can stay within that
space and stay within that space of
I think that the the speed with which we
get to a resolution is the speed with
which we succumb to a binary system of
yes as a nose yeah and I think that we
need to resist the binary system of
yeses and noes of likes and dislikes of
just the general modus of reaction of
overcoming the idea that human
communication should actually just be a
series of extreme reactions to one thing
or another and I think that in
reclaiming humane human communication
we're gonna be focusing much more on the
process of asking questions and trying
to have individuals who themselves are
aligned with a specific answer which is
the way that the current thought
leadership industry works great book by
the way from Daniel Dresner on the
thought leadership industry which I
highly recommend hey doesn't Dresner
Daniel jazz never thought leadership
industry that's right and bookmark yeah
definitely bookmark that and check it
out and there's one of my favorite
things to do and when I recommend books
is not to recommend the book that's
Umberto mmm
that's like when I'm in an email with a
series of great links and I open the
links up to ten thousand word articles
thinking that that was an easy way to
work through my email but ended up
creating a burden for my future where
add to pour through information in the
case of the book recommendation I
recommend reading very good book reviews
instead of reading the book and then
deciding if you want to read the book
just just just as a luck just as a life
hack yeah and there's some really good
publications that do good book reviews
but his book is important because I
think it outlines some of the thoughts
we've been through so far with regard to
the the importance of individuals who
become emblematic specific strains of
thought but then also the extent to
which that they can commandeer other
thinking through the territorial ization
on just the persistence with which they
have to assert yeah that they own a
specific thoughts base yeah yeah and and
the reason that they use these medieval
metaphors all the ones that you
mentioned in order to protect themselves
and psychic murder it's like a murder
moral outrage whatever tools are in the
arsenal at the moment is because it's
actually a very tenuous position to be
in it's quite easy to upend Fame and
popularity except for the people who
have reached the absolute highest
echelon those people are almost
unperturbed ball from their positions of
power but for that subset that quartile
of
same below it those positions are
actually easily upended by people like
yourself and hopefully with these
questions and so you were saying
reclaiming human conversation or
reclaiming human connection I'm not sure
we'd have to go back on the tape to say
what to hear what I said I'm not talked
about reclaiming human ability to have
these nuanced positions on things and
not just binary answers and no and that
word reclaiming is that like retron
chest nature of it it's a very dangerous
word to use yes it exposes me or others
who use a word like that to the attack
of like will it never really existed in
the first place about it and so how are
we gonna go back to a place that that
didn't exist ever so I think it's just a
growth into the sphere of having better
conversation or outstanding Congress
yeah by reclaiming I mean as a
proportion of the conversations that are
happening we might think to increase the
percentage that are devoted to being
okay with ambiguity for example or
uncertainty yes yes so I'm we're on
thought leadership and it's really it's
really fascinating I almost want to stay
here just a little bit longer I do want
to say her just a little bit longer so
maybe let's chat a little bit more about
the okay so with some of the with some
of the conversations will leak a little
bit into the Jordan conversation
something that I really thought was
interesting about him was that he was
telling people to clean up their room
and to put some of you some weight on
their back and you know built something
into the world and I thought that was
really good and really insightful for
actualization and Tony Robbins does
quite a bit of that as well and not only
is that kind of a crucial thing to do in
life is to find that essence that bliss
and build it into the world and make
that value in the world but also is
how that relates to as you climb up
these structures this genetic fitness
landscape of people that have the
rockets the space bubble and then they
have the genetic engineering bubble and
there's always people at the top of
those spheres as you kind of climb up
the plane on one of those or you try and
jump to another one and talk to people
on that one the interactions that happen
between the people identifying the
thought leaders and the people that are
trying to talk to those at the top of
those little parabolas on the landscape
that that is something that I find
really fascinating that interaction
between those people as that person is
trying to come up and engage in an ER
for the most part the those individuals
that you're speaking about genetic
fitness on an individual level
these aren't individuals anymore like
I'm not going to name names so I think
we're talking about these space-cadet
humans who are interested in
transcending the the not just what it is
to live on earth but even transcending
the definition of the human so that they
can territorial eyes a an idea that only
they can be within like it's not enough
to just remove yourself economically
from the conditions of other humans or
remove yourself geographically through
the usage of private jets and domicile
in far-flung countries out of
convenience or through large investment
but you need to literally remove
yourself from the earth or remove
yourself entirely from the category or
the kind of what it is to be human in
order to see some sort of self elyda t
these are individuals who have defined
themselves through their supremacy and
then define themselves through their
self perception of their superiority and
at a certain point in time you acclimate
to that you acclimate to a kind of a
social distance that you have to others
and then you're stretched you're like in
your 40s or 50s and you've got billions
tens of billions 100 more than a hundred
billion dollars and you're going how am
I going to demonstrate to myself and to
all the people around me that I am so
distinct from them such that I'm a cat
of my own what is the what is the list
that I can put myself on that only has a
room for one person well this is this
feeling that I have from these
individuals and you created through
mechanisms that are apparatuses that
extend individuals into corporations and
large-scale systems such that we equate
the individual with the process of
reformulating the material fabric of the
surface of the earth via their
organizations like the way that Tesla
needs to get rare earth metals to come
to a place to be worked formulated with
technology from Japan or the we're just
the restoring of the atoms on the
surface of the earth by Amazon's
functions and I think it's important to
just de-emphasize the individual here
and especially as you can as you
confront the the Jordan Petersons of the
world and any of those individuals that
appear to have this scintillating ly
clear notion of individual
responsibility we need to recognize that
we're actually we are in this together
we are deeply intertwined why people are
in the condition that they're in is not
necessarily because of themselves yeah
it could be a product of the world we've
built around us genetic or epigenetic
factors we know that geography is
destiny we know that the zip code is the
greatest predictor of the outcomes of
life yes and these are not people's
fault and so into the worlds into which
they're born
you can't just irresponsibly tell people
they need to buck it up and face the
world with a new level of masculine
aggression and it knows only if they do
that then everything is fall into place
for them
and by the way fall into place in what
way what is the outcome of this
masculine aggressive form of self
formulation or discovery so as much as
it is the role of the individual to find
their essence it's also the role of the
collective to be open and vulnerable and
loving and compassionate with one
another to help build that future where
it becomes easier to be actualized and
waits the it's the dichotomy of the
frame of the individual versus
collective that I'm bristling about yeah
it's it's the notion that we're
especially in these moments of
vulnerability who
we're the vulnerable are who check out
Tony Robbins or find their way to Jordan
Peterson's ideas I don't know if it's
ideology I don't I haven't read in the
books I can't i can't say i don't
actually know him that well these
vulnerabilities are based upon
individuals who themselves feel as if
they've become victimized by large-scale
systems and instead of going wow i've
been victimized by a large-scale system
we're having the acuity to realize that
they've been victimized by large-scale
systems understanding the operations of
large-scale systems then potentially
agitating or becoming political around
the formulation of large-scale systems
they somehow have been convinced by
these cult of personality individuals
that really they're the problem
they've been pathologized they've been
victimized by a system they've then been
pathologized and then they're being told
that it's up to them in order to engage
in a form of self rescue despite the
fact that their plight wasn't
necessarily of their own sometimes it is
I'm not one to say but in most cases
these are systemic effects and in most
cases you can trace systemic breakdown
to the individual effects that people
have that make them vulnerable to this
kind of dichotomous thinking that's
propagated by these cult of personality
thought leader individuals so it's a
good way to talk about the impact that
an organization is having on the world
is by talking about the people that are
doing things like do all of the
janitorial staff at Google replaced by
robots those are useless humans that
don't deserve to live that's not me
talking of course I mean I'll do that
occasionally but this is it
no keep going yeah are you a personality
in the show yes he does he comes into
the conversation oh that's awesome okay
I've actually never I've actually never
seen your show but you got you guys go I
mean I got nothing to add a lot of big
words for me you know I to what I'm what
I'm doing is like there is a
subconscious mind that is engaging in a
process of color commentary
that internalizes the words that are
spoken to them and I just yeah you know
janitors [ __ ] them they brought it on
themselves janitors brought it on
themselves they were the ones that
grabbed the mop they were the ones who
decided that this was gonna be the
course of their lives and so therefore
they should be held responsible for
their own actions preposterous right
she's making me want
I'm literally tearing up yeah
preposterous right I'm not saying that
all the viewers internalized what you
had said in that same way but some did
people are being conditioned right now
to believe that certain human beings are
unworthy of being human and that's the
class-based speciation potentially that
could be happening like you were
discussing about humans wanting to
differentiate themselves so much not
just geographically and economically but
even more so change their genetic code
add it added all these different types
of augmentations to their humanity that
differentiates themselves so far that it
becomes a speciation where the humans
can't even I can't even imagine how
little spirituality somebody has to have
in order to think those thoughts about
other people not having the right nut oh
it's the spectacle of the untethering
like if you live in if you are living in
a precarious time I think that we're
very much still living out the financial
crisis from about ten years ago or so
like we're still sorting us out we
really didn't deal with it we're not
gonna go into you know financial crimes
that were involved and the fact that
they were unpunished and that Wall
Street bonuses were up 17% this last
quarter and this is these are the sort
of your time of puppeteering before the
meat puppets move to the extent that the
meat puppets are actual puppets they're
being puppeteered by these large-scale
entities that are far from them I'm not
talking about conspiracies or Illuminati
I mean I'm spending time in these worlds
I consider myself to be an investor
myself so these are these are my friends
and I'm in this world of the deployment
of capital just this simple as coca-cola
high-fructose corn syrup
open happiness all
slogan all this kind of stuff right sure
but I think that what were what we're
witnessing in this moment is a live
memory that's been embodied within the
core of people that your reality can
change irrevocably and instantaneously
in a way that you can't understand
that's what the main lesson was from the
financial crisis of about ten years ago
yeah
something can happen yeah far away that
you don't really understand yes that
changes your fortunes in an instant the
inverse or corollary of that is
cryptocurrencies yeah it's the allure to
treat that as a kind of mirror state
like something can happen very far away
that you don't fully understand that can
change your fortunes immediately an
instant and instantly and we have these
yes dreams these extremes of Unknowing
and the extremes of ignorance that you
change your fortunes on the downside of
the upside yeah that are just symptoms
of the same sorts of extreme binary
reactions that people feel like they
need to have two people who are dividing
them to the Jordan Petersons or Donald
Trump's or or frankly the the people who
need to demonstrate their separation
from normal humans to the extreme or
what I just coined the spectacle of the
untethering that the person needs to
like detach themselves from any prior
definitions that would constrain them
we're not talking bout Heymann freedoms
anymore this is not about what does the
law say you can or cannot do or what can
you do upon others like we're already
with the extreme wealthy who I think
you're alluding to these like top of the
genetic fitness pyramids like they have
enough money that they've been able to
manipulate the law to their own ends
like and they've been doing this as
games the Bryan Holaday book that came
out of the documents the The Hulk Hogan
Terry Bollea versus Gawker case and the
financing from Peter Thiel and others
like and I don't need to will this list
you the other examples give it just a
quick summary of that as quick as
possible it's quick as possible yeah the
very quick summary is that well I mean
how do I do it in a way without picking
sides here I think it's important to of
course to to recognize that Gawker was a
publication that
had entities that were really kind of
bottom-of-the-barrel gossip mongers in a
way they had stumbled upon content or
the first part of the story is that they
had outed Peter Thiel as being a
homosexual which was widely known at the
time but it just wasn't in the press
this built up deep resentment in him
because he felt that this was a matter
of personal privacy he was looking for
an opportunity over the years in order
to sink Gawker permanently and had
somebody working on his behalf looking
for plaintiffs that he could support and
several years later a video of Hulk
Hogan having sex this is a professional
wrestler by the name of Tom Terry Bollea
was caught in security camera footage or
actually embedded in a kind of a fire
smoke detector of having sex with his
best friend Bob oh the love sponges wife
and this information was leaked several
years after that it was first leaked
Gawker decided to post it for whatever
inflammatory purposes and Howe Cogan
decided to sue that this is a case that
hogan may or may not have won depending
on the resources available to him but
with the infusion of the near infinite
wealth of a billionaire he was able to
get a settlement that I think I'd ended
up in the 130 to 140 million range for
himself and ended up bankrupting Gawker
and that was kind of the end of the
story whoa the lesson of the story in
this in this particular case
notwithstanding what you think about
well should this video of Hulk Hogan
having sex with his best friend's wife
be released on the internet and the
legal grounds of that and that's subject
to dispute the superficial description
of a very well capitalized individual
finding a plaintiff in order to
supercharger turbocharged their legal
efforts in order to bankrupt an entity
that had their they have a historical
grievance against this was a this was a
revelation of sorts that's a great way
to put it yeah so they their control so
they difficult politically said it so
the degree to which incredibly wealthy
people can shape public and narratives
the last manifestation of this NAV seems
quaint by comparison but reputation calm
was a company I think it still is around
and there's numerous other companies
that will scrape the internet for you
and scrub history in such a way that
people of the present will not
know what your actual past was they will
be forced wealthy people can force
humans of the earth to consume them only
in the version that they exist in the
present and not as a version as they
existed in the past
by changing public records or changing
the history of the Internet itself
through cease and desist letters and
letters potentially threatening
defamation of character to websites and
so we have this very sanitized version
of the past that's been cleaned up by
public figures of the present so that
the people in the present don't know the
true nature of their past and so
furthermore the people of the present
are forced to consume the powerful and
the wealthy in the present alone now if
you're very industrious and you can find
the Wayback Machine and you've no
investigative journalists or you know
how to find that information you can
find out people's pasts but the degree
to which the people in the present can
manipulate the notion of their bad
actions in the past has intensifies
considerably and the systems by which
humans in the present are living is is
reducing them to this present issed
notion whereby they're only able to even
discern the things that are brought to
them in the very instant and they have
the tools to look into the past but not
the kinds of tools that we thought that
would be at their disposal when we gave
birth to the Internet in the first place
these people at the top of a genetic
Fitness landscape still have to go to
the bathroom and poop and use toilet
paper to wipe their butt it's a it's a
it's a very humbling thought I think
that that would be a really nice quote
if you were to start putting minutes on
this wall the infusion of money into
changing society in the way that you can
not only take great advantage of
potentially other people and a political
and economic systems but even more so to
distance yourself so far from other
conscious beings that are not they're
not cows they're other humans now
they're cows
they're cows wrong well you know I like
my brisket mm-hmm how do you like your
brisket yeah you like it with throw that
Robo camera oh yeah I mean there they
are cows to a lot of those people not to
all of them but too many of them they're
so abstracted there's so many layers
away there they're just an image of a
microscopic civilization living under
40,000 feet of thin air or they're
abstracted through the through the data
about them and you look at how hard it
is for these people to to fake the
sincerity of real human connection like
this tour that Mark Zuckerberg went on
yeah
to kind of test out the credibility of
him as a political leader and just how
tone-deaf and how awkward he is
interacting with the meat puppets or the
meat the meat skins or whatever
derogatory term we use to describe the
deep wondrous complexity of the human
body but the way that he's been
abstracting those people through layers
and layers and layers of algorithmically
generated snapshots about who people are
and and and how people are serving his
best interests which is to productize
them for advertisers he's deeply
unconvincing and there are several other
people in that Escalon who are very very
human very very real and I don't want
this to be about like naming names of
who's the real and who's the not real
but one of the one of the great
pleasures of going to the World Economic
Forum every year is that I actually get
to spend time with some of these
individuals and have at least 2 to 5
minute conversation with them and that's
enough enough time to know what's behind
the person the human is leading your
world how do you enter that conversation
what do you do do you mean how do i
physically you know break down the gates
and and get myself to even be in a room
with those individuals or that and then
even further is do you do you what what
energy do you bring to the
to the first interactive to the first
engagement that you have with them the
first interaction are you making eye
contact and smiling are you coming in
with a hug well I read Robert Greene's
52 laws of power of the night before and
then I know I mean this is the just
going back to your bookshelf over here
I'm gonna break I'm gonna bring out some
books here yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna
bring out some books read Allie it's a
decent guy let's see oh there we go I
read these books yeah
cover to cover yep insane they're
literally conversations with the people
at the top and now I'm joking I'm
actually ingested this moment I don't
mean these specific books but listen
there's no there's no trick to it I
think that the people who are looking
for heuristics to be authentic are
always going to come across as as being
too contrived and I think that
heuristics are generally good principle
to to follow you know things like if 90%
of the people that are at these tops of
the genetic Fitness landscapes do things
like meditate in the morning and the
evening it's probably a good thing to
apply that to your life 90% of people at
the top of the genetic fitness landscape
this is a very problematic term that we
should talk about and probably yeah dis
abuse and dispose of as quickly as
possible but 90% of them are told that
this is something they should tell their
audiences in order to come across as
being deeply human and spiritual as well
you think looks like a genetic fitness
here okay let's let's you don't like
let's understand I'd like to to get to
that level is to have understood and and
Weil did as well as possibly manipulated
very large scale legal and social and
emotional systems ok board about the
opposite right you brought a lot of
value to the world you brought a lot of
competence very bust world and then you
did achieve to get to this top of this
yeah fitness landscape this competence
landscape let's call it in many cases
and then in many case you're looking at
the people who succeeded and if you ask
a person s now eating socially as well
some of them
yes just ask some of those people how do
they succeed or what led to their
success and and the most accurate and
humble and truthful answer is that a lot
of it was luck yeah what you're getting
is an incredible selection bias you're
getting a selection bias for the
successful and you're asking the
successful who themselves largely became
successful through an attribution bias
by congratulating themselves on their
own awesomeness to then tell you how
they became successful in the first
place and a lot of them are deeply
pathological because of the because of
the biased against thinking that things
are about luck a bias against thinking
that it was possible that other people
contributed to your success and this
very pernicious biased of self
attribution the reason that something is
the way it is is because the individual
who seems to be taking all the credit
for it
when in reality they're just a they're
an avatar for an incredibly complex
system via tens hundreds millions of
people were in the case of Facebook I
would say that this has got nothing to
do with Mark Zuckerberg this has to do
with an individual who happened to find
the levers and dials that just brought
out an extreme version of human nature
and that he should be taking far less
credit than he's actually getting and I
think that's exactly this bias this idea
that we should be celebrating the
individual whom it was elevated to this
hop that takes the reality away from the
population that built the platform in
the first place this is a large-scale
collective effort that happened to be
brought into being by a few individuals
who themselves wanted to take a
disproportionate amount of the credit
but this is a large scale very complex
organism that just happens to have a lot
of contributions to it while also at the
same time having just a few people were
taking all the credit for it yeah said
we need to totally destabilize this
notion of individual success we I know
Tim Ferriss not well we've met a bunch
of times I had a conversation with in a
South by Southwest last year around how
he has very little to say around how
people should exist together how people
should connect as groups how people
should should wield collective action
and collective deliberation and create
large-scale systems most of what these
individuals espouse have
to do with speaking to you as an
individual it goes back to this jordan
Peterson notion before of like you're
not adequate use an individual are not
adequate drawing a circle around Allen
and going Alan I'm really sorry to say
nice socks by the way
I'm really sorry to say but you are
separate from your environment separate
from your history separate from your
context separate from your city separate
from your friends separate from your
colleagues and whether or not you're
successful is entirely due to what
happens inside this arbitrary circle
that I just drew around you that goes
against everything that we understand
about physics about chemistry about
biology about sociology about psychology
about economics that's evolution this is
a mythology that's brought to people in
order to have a false sense of
confidence and it and to reduce the
cognitive burden around the complexity
of actual reality ok isn't it also true
that the circle around you and the
actualization that should come from
within you is also partly on your
shoulders sure
FL and then but then but then to just
say it's it's that is wrong and to just
say it's on the collective is wrong but
then there's some there's some beautiful
way to figure out like you said why are
authors like Ferris not writing about
how the collective should be shaped in
order to maximize flourishing I hope he
does I mean this is my great hope and I
encouraged him when I met him the last
time whatever was 13 months ago I asked
him why aren't you doing that I said
that that's that's really what we need
right now we don't need more Randian
ubermensch is running around the world
what we need are people who are thinking
in terms of the collective and he said
that's not my game that's not what I do
and he didn't mean to be dismissive he
was just being honest just like that's
not that's not my beat that's not what I
cover that's not how I communicate and I
think and I haven't heard him like
recently but I suspect based upon the
reactions that I'm getting
from people who do engage with his
content and Tony Robbins step to that
effect as well is that these individuals
are getting to begin to realize that
this is where the market is going for
them so it's not about their personal
evolution Tony Robbins and Tim Ferriss
are they can pivot the market with their
notes the other way around
I mean they're reacting to the market
that's what I'm saying but they've built
the market to be what it is by what
they've said yes as in they can pivot
the market by changing what they're
saying to be more hey let's figure out
we were put in control of this rock
let's figure out how to work together
but they're not saying those things on
their platform that's right because it
will require large-scale collaboration
and in most cases forms of sacrifice
yeah you certainly don't hear the people
who are pumping the virtues of
individualism speak in the terms of
sacrifice yeah it's the opposite
they speak in the very violent and
machine ik terms of war about slaying
enemies and conquering things we're
climbing things or fighting things or
routing things out but I think that the
market is there for them and I think
that the public is going to make itself
known in terms of its collective desires
such that these individuals who are
appealing to the individualism in people
are going to begin to appeal to the
collectivism in people yeah I think if
that's gonna happen it's also the
responsible thing and whether or not
they arrive at that through their own
meditations and reflections or because
both of these people are incredibly
data-driven and they're just gonna do
the things that their customers want
them to do it's inconsequential to me I
think that it'll be done with the same
level of success I'm really excited to
be a part of planting the seeds of
questions into culture to get people to
care more about the collectivism and
I think that's what we're doing with the
different topics that we speak about on
this program but also when we talk about
clean meat we talk about it in a way of
agricultural sustainability and when we
talk about robotics we talk about it in
a way of getting people out of the dirty
and dangerous jobs when we the clean
meat while I'm a cellular agriculture I
buy that entirely that's why we've been
looking to invest in cellular
agriculture companies the the argument
for robots getting people out of dirty
and dangerous jobs I buy that to some
extent you know I was talking with
somebody at a very large consulting firm
he runs a large consulting firm last
night and he was saying that you know
the Eli Whitney in the cotton gin and
what it had done to take people out of
dangerous and arduous work I I do I do
believe in that but I don't believe that
we have a really great consensus
definition of what our Jose is correct
because that most of the most of how how
most people conduct their lives to me is
almost inscrutable it's not that I think
it's arduous or non arduous I just I
can't really truly and honestly say that
I understand it so we're gonna get there
a lot of what we're talking about is
human design in general Hugh did the
design of humanity and the conversations
that are really important for us to be
having and so that's where these
questions come in and play these
questions these seeds that we can plant
throughout society and then give them
water and then let them grow and
flourish to be what they end up being
which they're just way past these
questions are way past our organic
bodies they're way past that that
mimetics
is way stronger than these genetics
which mean that's the questions the
questions of of what should we do about
globalization what should we do about
wealth inequality how will we
each AI and robotics ethics these
questions are far and large more
important than my then even my you know
that my my offspring my own offspring
because the it doesn't even matter if
you get your own offspring into the
world if the world ends up being
designed in a shitty way yeah well the
world is multiple things and that's the
first I'm looking at the globe there and
I'm staring at the continent that I'm
Africa yeah that I'm twice position like
yeah I was just talking a lot is it is
that so I love that place I haven't been
and I really thought how can you love a
place that you've never been because you
just because who doesn't love Africa you
just learned so much because you go to
Google Earth and you can you literally
observe so much you go to Wikipedia you
observe so much and you just get
obsessed with evolution and how culture
sprang up to be where it is and oh but
I'm looking at just to go back to the
point without losing it I'm looking at
Africa you're saying you know the world
is not necessarily placed that you want
to birth children into because of the
way that it's potentially being designed
against our best interests and against
the best interests of the planet itself
I think that empirically that's very
largely true but the world is very
uneven it has punctuation marks all over
the place and it matters where you're
born yeah and it matters the culture
that you learn and the culture that you
feel that you can impress into and have
impressed upon you and I'm looking at
African I'm looking at this vertical
spectrum and at the top I can see
Scandinavia and a country that I've been
to more than a dozen times Iceland these
are places that your this question of
you know do you live in a simulation
well I think it's like do you live in a
micro simulation yeah
if you live in Iceland you're kind of in
a simulation in the sense that it's the
same humans ish same planet ish but it
has an entirely different way of
governing itself that as the world
oldest democracy that's been around for
about a thousand years that has found a
way to deliberate tribal conflict and
resolve it in such a fashion as to
produce some pretty good compromises for
its population it has other
idiosyncrasies I don't want to talk
about Iceland specifically but it
doesn't matter where you're born yeah
and being born into the United States
right now is a is a very treacherous
thought but being born into a society
that will catch you if you fall because
we fall for all kinds of different
reasons is a very different thing than
being born into society that it would
actually celebrate your downfall because
some of the celebration of the of the
supersonic elevation and the untethering
of the powerful is also a celebration of
the people who are in the gutter I think
part of why in America I'm Canadian by
the way you should just get that out of
the way but part of why Americans
tolerate poverty is because it
relativistically if you're wealthy or
not or relatively wealthy you're able to
at any point in time know that you're
better than an average or know that
you've transcended some base level of
human existence around you and without
this large pool of people in poverty
without the opportunity to rubberneck
and then pass by at their suffering we
can't know for certain that we're doing
well for ourselves because we don't have
the cultural apparatus anymore or the
social capital' apparatus anymore to be
able to look at each other and go how
are we how are we doing right now I
don't ask you when I see you how are we
doing I ask you how are you doing yeah
you have to and I answer the question as
an individual how are we doing yeah so
this is a great question to propagate
that is a great question to propagate by
the way I figure that's so good that's
so so good just just because we ask it a
couple times per day so to change it to
just one different word in a very
standardized question it's a really good
way to start and what do you think will
happen next time like just imagine in
your head don't say the name of the
person
but the next person who you say who you
would have said how are you doing you're
gonna switch that to how are we doing
how do you think that that scenario is
gonna play out that person is likely
going to go that little yeah and then
though and probably and probably ask the
question which we like you're like me
and you like how are we doing like are
they most people yeah most people would
interpret that it's like allenge I say
something that offended you the last
time that we assume like that or there
will be other very unlikely that we need
effects and it's I'm Deanna that's right
but I think that even the the question
of we are which we to get that to the
Nexus submaster is it as an indication
of what the person is thinking about
yeah how are we doing well my company's
doing great thanks for asking how are we
doing well I was at the gun March this
weekend and March for our lives or how
are we doing well I saw the stormy
Daniels interview this weekend or how
are we doing well actually it's weird I
noticed that based upon my social
intimacy algorithm that you and I were
text messaging on average every 3.5 days
but your last text message was from
eight days ago you're good so try that
let me have that be really interesting
to do I like that one
how are we doing now you spoke about
something else which is the anti-natal
list movement this is a fascinating
strain of thinking that is has some
level of seriousness to it I'm not sure
have you looked at that at all um it's a
concept I'm so suicidal then potentially
we shouldn't be introducing any more
humans onto the planet until a point at
which we can stop me a recital yeah yeah
that's that's that's super interesting
I've been preaching about this whole the
medics over genetics thing trying to get
people to have more conversations about
the world that we live in in the world
that we should build prior to just
birthing more kids into this world so if
we prioritize procreation because of our
genetic
tendency and inclination proclivity to
do so then we we take a bat our ideas
about designing the planet take a
backseat to having children I don't
follow you can you say that again if we
allow our proclivity to have kids take
the front seat and have the back seat be
the discourse about how to design
humanity that is a recipe for disaster
I mean I think that the front lines of
designing humanity is is parenting yeah
I think that you know I I know I would
also argue meditation is there it's
spirituality Swami Ananda was just on
the show and he actually continued to
say that inner management and meditation
is the key to spirituality - who - is he
a guru propagating on meditation as an
anesthesia though sounds like he might
be in the business of selling meditation
to a spiritual leader and he's not
really selling meditation it's more that
he's you know you think about greed and
power and all these things that we've
been discussing a lot of them even
parenting a lot of them can be the
meditation does insane effect in affects
humans in insane ways that we don't even
understand but for example in parenting
the calm that we have in parenting the
more insight that we have into the way
that the child is observing the world
around them and being raised into the
world by you and then the same way that
meditation affects parenting affects the
way that you run your business you're no
longer looking at people in the eyes and
thinking that this person is a [ __ ]
janitorial slave you're thinking about
them like this is their life journey
well ideally I mean it turns out that
yeah that you need to be guided in a
meditational process for it to unlock
all these other
tributes of compassion empathy it's not
automatic a lot of people meditate
because they're trying to make rational
decisions I think the birth of
meditation as a corporate core
corporatized practice at least in the
first iteration as I remember it was
largely about people making rash
emotional decisions and this is a way to
at least observe your emotions as they
were forming such that see to the degree
you wanted to incorporate emotions into
your decision-making they weren't taking
you over as if you were possessed by
them but that you could incorporate them
in a same rational way that you could
incorporate reasonable cognitive
thinking so it comes from a different
strain as to how it became popularized
via corporate corporatization obviously
meditation is a tremendous tool I'm a
huge advocate of it but it's like a
intellectual reflex that people just say
like well clearly what we need to do is
meditate more and if we meditate more
than everything's going to be fine I
remember being on a trip with about 85
very talented high potential individuals
of approximately of my stature and age
and we were at a in a geography that was
very very complicated and on any given
day if there was something that was
confrontational or complicated that we
were being confronted with in invariably
somebody in the group would be like I
think it's time to meditate we would get
in a circle and we would meditate for
some amount of time five ten fifteen
minutes and then carry on with our day
meditation in that context I just I
don't mean to pick on that context but
meditation in that context and in a lot
of other context is a way of dissolving
tension finding yourself in a place
that's inexplicable and then dissolving
it away by making it in some ways vanish
disappear otherwise just melt into the
fabric of reality and it's a way of
smoothing out your emotional response to
external stimuli which might actually
require you to have potentially compat
of discourse around the stimulus so I
see it both ways I see it as an
intellectual reflexive like you got to
chill out and you got to meditate more
and and also as this
possible tool to strip people from the
agency of the discourse of combative
reality but let me just go back quickly
to parenting I meant to say it very
literally like the design of the planet
to the extent that our definition of the
planet is contingent on human beings and
we should destabilize that notion
considerably as well our fixation that
the planet is by and for humans is
something that we should destabilize in
the same way that we're destabilizing
the notion of individual individualism
our individual attainment but let's just
say that we have that notion that the
perpetuation of the planet is contingent
upon the reproduction of the human then
this is the this is the beginning of
human design this is the beginning of
civilization design but just like I was
saying before as I'm looking at Africa
and Scandinavia still you can be born
into the United States and get zero
paternity leave or get very
discriminatory maternity leave and a
very little time to spend with your kids
and have your kids raised by iPads
yeah worse I mean worse a lot of people
can't afford iPads in there I mean
they're kids raised in the old-fashioned
way television in a lot of places that
that I would consider to be very lucky
places to be born into there might be a
year of paternity leave or a year of
maternity leave you might have people
from from some outside entity come visit
you on a daily basis to answer any
questions that you might have with
regard to the complexities of raising
children and also giving you tips and
tricks as to how to raise very healthy
and well-adjusted children those places
exist in this world right now it's not
like we need to de novo design them from
scratch they do exist and they're there
waiting for us to be inspired by but
part of being inspired by them is
refashioning our own society to possibly
admit that the tools and techniques that
we've used at this point are failing us
yeah and that's a really hard thing to
do yeah
I'm glad that we're in parenting and
meditation as we come to a pretty close
to to an end I we've talked about
nothing that you put on that board
I'm obsessed and talk about planetary
health human augmentation social needs
globalization we talk to you we're gonna
have to have a round - we have to have a
couple rounds yeah I both of those last
two topics are massive to unpack just to
touch on them let's see if I can do it
quick
with meditation I am in agreeance with
what you're saying it's important to me
to not just step away from the discourse
in order to in order to meditate but in
order to know how to Aquinas lis
approach nuanced discourse one does need
to meditate you can't approach nuanced
discourse without meditation because
nuance this course does not occur from
well anyway let's put that aside now you
had to get out of there now moving to
parenting cuz I know we can get a good
job family I spend a lot of time
unpacking that you you need you need the
meditation to have a nuanced discourse
and so there's that and then the
parenting side of things I've been for a
long time propagating the thought of
every single parent is a deity to their
child you'd the child is born into the
world the parent is the God to the child
the parent is then responsible for
enriching the child's life to a degree
of where that child is not only aware of
the world that they were born into but
also possess some sort of awareness of
their own body as well as awareness of
the moral structures of society to be a
strong
person of value that ends up being
brought into the world every single one
of those things I mentioned are very
subjective and difficult to define the
awareness of the world around you the
awareness of thyself as well as the what
you're gonna build into the world those
are very subjective things but I've been
trying to build a curriculum of what
some of those things should be it's
great and let me help let me help you
with that if you want to offline I I
would I would I so kids like that the
parent says gods or goddesses I don't I
don't I don't know we can talk about
that later but let's just say to some
extent metaphorically they are they need
to be judged by their actions and in
most cases those parents are working
like dogs they are where you chimed in
it and those lives those lives are very
kind to do the raising of the child into
the increasing the awareness of the
child and so what do gods like let's
continue this further this thought
experiment what do gods in our society
do from the vantage point of children
well they get into cars which represent
their identities they drive off to
places that are hard to untangle and
understand they spend a lot of time
there and then they come home and
complain so you know that they're
devoted to this fuzzy notion of the
collection of resources so that kids can
acquire instant gratification through
consumerism we don't really know what
parents do at work a lot of humans don't
know they do at work sometimes I don't
know what I do it's hard to describe and
then we come home and then that's the
thing that that occupied the majority of
our lives and then occasionally there's
like a moralizing 1950's dad or mom like
telling their kids about how to behave
but we should be judged by our actions
and the majority of people are are going
to work in a way that is invisible to
their children and that's not a swipe
against work I think work is really
really important yeah yeah but it's also
potentially a swipe against the the
exposure that we do give our kids to the
actual knowledge of the ethical
decisions that go on on a daily basis or
to that or to the grand ethical decision
about what am i doing in the world how
have I chosen to spend my time on this
earth yeah as a core principle yes so
that you can learn from me based upon
that biggest decision yes yes so that
you know if anybody ever asks what is
your mom or dad do you can say it
saintly and just blanket statement go
sounds like that their life is filled
with meaning and that what they do is an
instantiation of their moral systems the
ik said that they have one yeah
the other dimension which I think
touches on the earlier one and we're
looking at Africa and we're looking at
Scandinavia these apparent polar
opposites but indeed they're not and I
just
that's an apples in orange comparison to
all my African friends you may ever see
this I'm not comparing the entire
content of Africa there's so much
diversity inside of it but what we have
is a system in for example Scandinavia
whereby you can rely on your culture to
do parenting for you we're not all of
the pressure on the raising of quality
children is on the parents and this is
where I wanted to make sure that we were
on the same page with the metaphor of
the deity the deity is just a pert is
just the first line of connection into
the birth and the responsibility and
then the second line of connection are
the community around them that can then
also be these deities that help and have
that help guide the child through a
prosperous life so I agree with the
notion of community and parenting a lot
as well
and unfortunately the notion of
community itself is being eviscerated to
the point of being useless if I hear
Mark Zuckerberg talk about community one
more time I mean we have lost the notion
of community a lot of this came from the
economic and social mobility that the
economy affords people and the
assumption that we should be traveling
physically from one place to another
uprooting our families so that our kids
who had friends in one place need to
break off those friendships in order to
develop friends in another place or so
that the intimate relationships that
they had with their grandparents or
uncles and aunts get cut off and then
they you go somewhere else and then it's
just automatically assumed that humans
should be able to form deep intimate
bonds immediately and instantaneously
there's a lot of assumptions with regard
to the way that we vaunt the notion of
economic and social mobility that
actually leads to the fraying of actual
communities which I would define as
having something to do with the sharing
of scarce resources and a material
reality yeah so we have a whole nother
conversation about
how to design the future that I think we
touched on a little bit now and I'm just
like I am so grateful this has been
amazing probably my favorite
conversation on the show thanks brother
are we over are we wrapping up that's
what's happening we do we do have to
wrap I really want to keep it up it's
like we could talk for so long you're
not gonna ask me about the stimulation I
should I should ask you a couple
Gordon's let's ask a couple course I do
I do like I listen to just a few
podcasts and Tyler Collins podcast I
find usually fairly good and he has that
segment in the middle where he asks
people underrated overrated have you
seen that segment at all I think it's
really nice it's like a natural break in
the conversation yeah you go from this
like I'm a guest you're an interlocutor
like I'm blah blah blowing I'm
bloviating and you're occasionally
chiming in to clarify things or ask for
their questions and it just makes it
very formulaic and so all the guests on
a weekly basis get to answer a similar
format of questions and he just says
something like you know tea overrated or
underrated and then you have to say very
quickly if it's overrated and most
people can be evasive about something as
innocuous yeah I'm polarizing it yeah
but I really I really like that's cool
yeah so the plug it in in the middle
might be interesting we do plug in at
the end these questions let's ask you
about what is something that you believe
that nobody else believes to be true hmm
it's hard for me to know what other
people believe again I've said this
earlier in our conversation but I don't
make any assumptions about what people
know what people believe or what is even
knowable or believable so it's to try to
not be evasive let me come back to that
one that's a really hard one to answer
over there because part of it I could
give an answer but then it's like what
you don't believe that somebody else
believes that well questions a bit of a
triage to say it and even then we could
say that oh yeah a very small percentage
of people think that or whatever from
your general analysis of society yeah
yeah all right let me throw out one I've
noticed it's been bubbling up and I in
speaking to a good friend this morning
it bubbled up again
and it's not necessarily belief yet I
would just say it's a very inchoate
thought but it's at least motivating me
in some regard conceptually I think that
the outrageous extremism and reactionary
nature of human communication that's
being elicited by the social platforms
that people are on right now is somehow
if tenuously if super tenuously but
somehow connect it to the binary nature
of computation itself so getting people
to go through these sort of yes/no
arrangements of like I agree or disagree
or I agree or disagree on some extreme
degree and rather than taking these
nuanced positions in the Middle where
you defend them and discuss them but the
notion of polarization at Salif work or
just let's just say intensification it's
almost a better way of saying that then
given any response intensify or amplify
to the extent that it occupies an
extreme so that from a distance it looks
like a binary kind of arrangement I
think that that process if tenuous I
agree it could be super tenuous is
related to the fundamental binary nature
of computation it's fascinating
the next question is each attention are
we a computer simulation you know right
there in that question yeah in that in
there then I didn't I didn't answer that
question well I think so well that's
this is good that's a good segue into
that question it definitely is that's a
really good that's a really good one so
it's more of it I answered your question
in an evasive way in the sense that I
basically said all right there's a few
thoughts that I that that that I
incubate for long periods of time and I
have a bunch of other ones that aren't
ready to be released in conversation
that's a really good one that's an
interesting one that has been bubbling
up that I'm now testing and getting you
know PhD mathematician friends of mine
so just like shoot down entirely or but
it seems to be something that's
grounding my my paltry mind with regard
to I I really like that one and see and
I think it really relates with people to
say that so many people that say that
although the brain is just computing
what the person would it's perceiving
that that can be a good way to get
people to understand that they are just
gravitating towards the zeros and ones
rather than all the nuance in the middle
computers don't go to nuance in the
middle there's a way of representing the
middle or what we used to call the
mesosphere this is a fascinating space
between the macro between the macro
sphere in the microsphere these like
inner cities but their miso sphere
itself first time I heard or like the
comparison between Osmos and them and
the atoms yeah the miso spheres yeah so
we haven't had a chance to talk about
info allottee as an m e me mes Osram you
know not not me so like I so I so
friendly no not that me so okay no okay
nor the Koji spore based Japanese
condiment not that miso either but it's
a it's a scaler attribution to this kind
of middle level lies at house it's both
mes oh yeah
some people know that does kind of seem
like yes okay
nothing nothing related but nice elision
there I like that productive confusion
so but let me let me just because you
said it and I want to point it out you
just talked about you were in some ways
character Turing people talking about
the brain this is another thing that we
need to dissolve immediately this notion
of the individual like being able to
draw a circle around the person be like
well it's all Alan's fault he had it
coming for him that lazy schmuck the
same thing like the nature of the human
is in the hippocampus or the idea of why
Alan is acting the way is is because his
prefrontal cortex hasn't turned on fully
yet because he's still or her 17 years
old leg bill is over-reactive exactly so
this idea of the second circle of the
brain where I'm not gonna draw a circle
around your head is if I was gonna
decapitate you go ahead draw it on me
too but in this idea of like an
isolation of the individual or the
decapitation of the cerebrum these are
such baseless notions because of the way
that the brain has both infused within
the body and then through the idea of an
extended cognition infused as a as a
world which itself is a mental process
cognition is infused in the world
it's infused in each other we've become
more each other as a result of being
together as a result of doing this
together that if you hear people talking
about well there's just this part of the
brain that explains everything that
should just be immediately disregarded
and disabused in the same way that
drawing in a separate server on the
individual should be disregarded and
disabused these are the mind viruses
these are the bad mind viruses that
perpetuate sloppy thinking and
inaccurate depictions of reality this is
not by itself this is not by itself it's
part of the whole yes it actually is and
the sign of spiritual belief that's the
yeah that is it and and even though it's
not by itself and it is part of the
whole it is also it's it is also brain
inside of skull perceiving reality and
so because of that there is then also
some responsibility in here as well to
also find even though the world outside
might not be fine-tuned for the perfect
being there must also be some sort of
recognition of this being in here trying
to go and seek what that is that that
perfection are whatever it may be
I just I can't get sold on just the
collective thinking I think there is
some individualism thinking that we
still need a unpack and talk about oh no
doubt I mean we are we are
instantiations of collective ideals and
so even though these I'm appointed Tony
Robbins and tip Sapolsky book and just
its come from human evolution for so
long that you're microbes are dictating
what you're eating more than you are and
that your your ancestry to down the line
is the reason why you reacted the
certain way to what happened not just
you I have free will and I reacted this
way so it's you're right I mean that's
been one of the interestingly in
parallel with the financial collapse
from ten years ago
approximately
approximately is both the rise of
meditation as a corporate practice and
behavioral economics as something that
is broadly familiar amongst people who
are generally well-read you know people
who are reading about its first key and
Kahneman like you can take insight this
information why is this relevant because
it is going towards the destabilization
of the notion of the rational individual
and we should really thank them for that
I've never once said the individual has
got nothing to do with it yeah correct
it's more about it's more about the
posture that we take with regard to you
know the thing right the world is
screwed everything around me is working
against me and yet I can step up as some
super heroic figure and defy the nature
of my immediate reality by impacting
onto it in such a way that I can
effectively disregard it and pretend
that it's not even there but you can
impact onto it and make the world better
and then make a good cycle out of that
that's a great way to do it so I think
that you're right about people like
Kahneman that are making that really
clear ok let's let's go into so that was
a really great thought that you had I
really like that and I think it really
relates well with our human our ability
to have discourse as well as computers
that's really interesting how about how
about a the ones and zeroes how about
are we alone in the cosmos are we alone
in the cosmos and who's we in that one
sorry like just the question before that
asks you how are we who's the we and are
we alone in the cosmos so this rock is
the plant humans Homo Sapien this rock
is the the life on Earth is an ocean of
life yeah life as whatever way we define
life is life solely on this rock on this
rock in the broader cosmos yeah I'm
gonna answer no and unequivocally no
just because of my definition of life is
not about biology necessarily and I
factored in physicality into a broader
Network arrangement of
life is so the moon for example and yeah
now the moon has microbes on it I don't
mean to talk about in that regard but
just even mythologically or as an object
which has always had object miss to it
is now a subject and has been a subject
for tens of thousands of years since
humans had the capacity to look up it
factored into a kind of a mythology that
then affected the way that we told
stories and motivated ourselves or
navigated the oceans and so for me the
lot the moon has life that speaks to my
kind of neo-paganism or neo animism as a
just how I am guided and I understand
that I'm stressing there is planetary or
life on the life of Saturn or the life
of Titan or the life of these other
exactly so I I mean I I understand that
the biologists might hear what I'm
saying and say well I think that what
we're talking about is you know
carbon-based life forms the metabolic
processes cellular structures any kind
of agency or or even just when you're
talking about it from this motto oh
Jesus pick pants I guess it's not even
yeah it's it's pants Ike's ism is
different and that's that would be
another response to the same question
but it's more that my definition of life
is such that these things are already
incorporated into our notion of the
conscious creation of reality and so
that they themselves are folded into our
broader definition of what life is yeah
okay I don't believe that okay let's
find an inanimate object like I don't
believe that this is living in and of
itself but it's in a network of
arrangements of life such that it
effectively approximates life so it's a
part of life if we're observing the
stars and we're naming the stars and
we're looking at them and looking at
other planets then those are alive
because we're observing them
experiencing them that's a bit of a
stretch but I but something to that
pathetic side effect is what is what I'm
about my first reaction to okay how
about advanced civilizations roaming the
cosmos and from no idea okay I mean I I
you know I could talk about Boltzmann or
I could tell you about the probabilities
of this existing that we didn't sink
that if you if you could just give us a
binary on this one yes or no is there an
advanced civilization roaming the
roaming the cosmos there's there's a
there's something about the answer which
speaks to a way of absolving ourselves
from living in reality right now okay
but I would also argue that there is a
beauty to the answer that enriches our
state of existence yeah the short answer
is we are the advanced civilization
roaming the ultimately we can get to
that point yeah no I think we are I mean
we are in the beginning version of
society and back yeah so yeah I think
that I think that we're there are there
in a star treky and fashion like our are
there spaceships or other modes of
quantum teleportation from one place to
another happening in the cosmos I would
I would say I would like to believe that
but but I don't do you think we're in a
computer simulation no why do you think
this is based reality I think that
people use the notion of simulation to
distance themselves from
responsibilities that they have okay and
their real lives argue on the other side
of it which is that the idea of
understanding a computer simulation also
gives unique insight in perspective into
the world that we live in I think people
are desperate to believe in something
like a simulation so that they could
absolve themselves of having to make
tough choices I'd I would I would say
that that is a perspective to have on it
and then the another perspective to have
on it is that it can give these really
profound understandings of the world
that we live in as well as what the
potentials are of worlds and I think
that is consciousness expanding enough
to not absolve me from my duties but
more so so that's my perspective mother
no I agree yeah but I would say you
think it's called simulation series I
would say that when I see people talking
about the simulation it's a way to kind
of put ourselves in our place and then
allow us to cauterize and that this is
kind of a meditation for geeks to talk
about the simulation it's like let's
just go and talk about it for 10 minutes
and you cauterize that thought process
around how things ought to be to the
extent that we can can individually or
collectively and or together yeah
accomplish something in the world so I'm
just exciting
pointing it out as a cauterization
mechanism for actually stripping
ourselves from our own agency isn't it
also interesting though to think about
it like how should we design humanity
isn't that a principle of of
understanding what a simulation okay if
you were to be a designer or a
programmer of the world well how would
you design or program it and so these
sort of potentials need to think about
it but it doesn't resolve in that like
if if we had a manifestation of the
simulation that allowed individuals to
actually be designers of the simulate
simulated world in which they were
operating to enact ideas inside of it I
would be very much for that world but it
also turns out that is what our world is
but if you believe if you're in that
world and you believe in the simulation
and you think that we have no free agent
no free will or agency then you end up
just kind of being blase about things or
worse you end up having those
attribution biases where you go look at
me I'm so [ __ ] successful it's
because the simulation made it so do you
do you think that do you think that
there is a meaning or purpose its life
expressible in a single sentence or I
think that there's not one but I think
that there's many and I think that many
of them are not currently accessible to
us because we don't speak all the
relevant languages what are some of and
don't have all the imaginations to be
able to picture them what are some of
them meanings and purposes of life
let's pick it up on another conversation
okay I feel little Jack's medicine at
the moment how about this and that's a
note that's an opening to a series of
other decisions very simple one then
maybe simple I'll tend what is the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world an object a
thing the most beautiful thing in the
world
the thing can be anything
I think it's the whole world good answer
it's incredibly beautiful I mean yeah
and and and beautiful in the way that
it's incredibly surprising and that it
like the to the extent we are being
stripped from the narrative and the
drama around the relationship between
humans and the world and that we have
this antipodal oppositional narrative
it's being told about humans versus
planet it's some you know Marvel mashup
where we're gonna come to some final
battle to see who wins like this is a
fascinating thing for me to witness
because the truth is obviously that
we're looking for symbiosis we're
looking for we're looking for ourselves
to be having an economic system that's
ecologically rooted that is based in the
reality of our planet and it doesn't act
on a rival risk or exclusion
exclusionary fashion against other
people whereby this quest to be the
super human untethered spectacle of
separating ourselves from from humans
themselves doesn't mean that you're
actually making it worse for other
humans that we can somehow balance out
the greed and selfishness that we have
with the desire for belonging and
connection the fact that we have a
planet that has all these tensions on it
that are appear to be irresolvable and
yet we have certain weak signals as to
how we might be able to resolve these
things and live dare I say in harmony or
just symbiotically which i think is a
better better frame or mutualistic aliy
yeah I think it's the great narrative
the great drama of our age and that yeah
as a narrative is the most beautiful
overarching narrative it's the ultimate
mythology placed on the ultimate stage
with the ultimate exactly combatants and
antagonists / protagonists who are
battling against each other while what's
really happening is that they're
battling against themselves I think that
this is a this is a beautiful story on a
beautiful planet you heard it here
you heard it here from Joshua Kaufman
this is the human story the human
narrative this is probably the most
interesting thing that can be discussed
is kind of what is going on on this
plane
how are we gonna move forward we're
grateful for the cosmos giving us
consciousness let's let's figure out
what to do action items start asking how
are we doing that's a really good one
put that into practice see what happens
send us some email simulation series at
gmail.com let us know what you have
experienced comment below in this video
what you experienced when you asked that
will highlight a comment we'll put in
the bio how are we doing instead of how
are you doing also another good good
action item is just in general think
about designing humanity think about
what what world we should live in how we
should get there how we should design it
so I am I'm just so grateful for where
we went with this conversation
definitely my favorite one yet it was
very cool thank you brother thanks for
the opportunity and I look forward to
seeing you around all the time given
that we Sheriff's City even if you can't
see the city here yeah and and helping
you guide this series of questions
together I would also remind your your
audience to live the question yeah
exactly so yeah living the question has
been another fundamental pillar of what
we've been discussing
let's get that the the cultural
dissemination of the question into more
people's lives and thank you for tuning
in if you guys have found this content
useful give us a like give us a comment
give us a subscribe we want to inspire
more people to build the future and if
you would like to join the community we
have a growing patreon community we
would love your support you get access
to cool exclusive content live events
ahead of time our book that's coming out
soon our global leaders book it's gonna
be super exciting you'll be doing a
portrait photo soon
huge shout out to Ron Vargas our
director and producer
and that's it we have Jared Faison
coming up at 3 o'clock we're excited for
that one so stay tuned and we'll drop
that one soon thanks out thank you see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]